desobediencia o hartazgo un año de
pandemia y los contagios están
disparados en europa sin embargo los
mensajes iniciales de quedarse en casa
parecen ser historia para muchas
personas en berlín alemania por la noche
se suceden las fiestas ilegales y por el
día las manifestaciones anti
restricciones creo que tenemos que hacer
algo en contra de las restricciones no
simplemente dejarlo estar y no hacer
nada aceptando lo que decida el
parlamento también en alemania a los
cientos de manifestantes de berlín en
stuttgart se contaban por miles sin
mascarilla y sin distancia social en el
país vecino en bélgica este viernes se
celebró en bruselas el segundo día de
una fiesta que terminó con choques entre
la policía y los juerguistas se calcula
que hubo 5.000 asistentes mientras las
restricciones limitan a cuatro personas
las reuniones en francia en la noche
previa a la entrada del confinamiento su
capital parís vio todo tipo de fiestas
clandestinas para este brasileño es
imposible encerrarles en casa
si hay un problema si la ley en los
prohíbe nosotros con un control o de un
camino para encontrarnos encontrarnos y
salir un poco esta regla nosotros como
consideramos un poco ridículo y estás en
domicilios pero también en el espacio
público así festejan los turistas en las
playas de barcelona en españa la policía
impide que la gente se divierta nadie
está causando problemas pero nos impiden
festejar
la opinión pública de estas prácticas
como una desobediencia perjudicial para
la sociedad mientras que del otro lado
las restricciones son vistas como una
forma de coartar la libertad para una
pandemia que no consideran como tal